okay it's a boy psychobabble with a
clean equation and we're just finishing
off the Brotherhood got a main man here
Donald Trump and a hazmat suits all's
good okay hey I don't like this cat hey
Shawn yeah I was so worried I thought I
never seen is it true that is our that
trust me really as long as you don't
leave oh you're not don't worry okay Oh
before I forget father uh shut the [ __ ]
up ok let's devastate us um where is it
nope all way up there with the [ __ ] okay
I'll just walk up there geez asses
[ __ ] up that is beyond [ __ ] out I
can't i've seen some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I
can't you know I wanna pawn a baseball
bat in her [ __ ] so lay's us okay okay
and I want this as you know what that
says
mm-hmm what the [ __ ] is that no no it
can't they someone's coming
out of my way horses out of my way
I don't think
I need to go for the face yeah I
understand right
cellos and over here Oh what the [ __ ] is
this out of here trice s
yeah I'll fact that but ok i know i'll
just saw in what is it a rock ok ok
that's how can disgusting tell you [ __ ]
up that some people you know ok ok
and got a lotta AML in this [ __ ] and I
intend to use that
who shut the helmet off [ __ ] hey oh
[ __ ] ok ok [ __ ] [ __ ] that's fine yeah
buddy
how can I rhythmic Valentine hey go
ahead on him
well he attacks i run over here you
check crippled arm
I'm so thirsty disparity water of course
oh hey
Jesus what the [ __ ] is that
you
where my main man [ __ ] can I guess which
is a fat man dad you know you know how
it is like
the [ __ ] is going on over there
then another one mm-hmm ok a time were
put back to Pam
[ __ ] shot others they look up to you
yeah sure my new dia kash has been
identified assistance requested in
recovery
maybe later timetable for this task is
not critical you know that vertibird
from red glare well Tom and the boys
fueled it up and it's red
the Brotherhood patrols been dealt with
processing processing complete
okay well that is the come up in
equation touch thank you